[Music]
you have been married now almost exactly
one year you came on our show when you
were about to get married
yes and now it has been about a year how
is married life married life is is great
I've learned a lot this first year yeah
I already laughing no because you know
the first year you're trying to figure
out you're being honest about everything
and and then you realize you're an idiot
because now I just lie about everything
and it's perfect wait mate you you were
honest at first I was honest for about a
year about what kinds of things like
like you know like I'm gonna go play
golf or 18 holes yeah you know now I'll
just say hey I have a three hour meeting
you've learned that it's better just to
lie in life in general I think it's
better just I think that's good for here
my wife's actually yes you know if
anyone has the couch I can see one
tonight it's right there power thank you
sure
Randy's sitting on it right now the
cuddle party tonight okay your your wife
incredibly beautiful former Miss India
yes Neha yes yes Nia last name is is
Kapoor yeah couple yeah and so it's two
syllables yeah
yes so is Conan but yeah everyone calls
you corn and then yeah everywhere people
like Regis show up in four years it's
like a code name I just I don't know if
you can hear that well that's right way
but you know my my parents my parents in
India called you Conan yes yeah they're
like are you gonna be on Conan yes and
I'm like yes III also used to call you
Conan and most people do I actually
stopped minding it because it sounds
more heroic Conan you know don't you
think so
no yeah
what's this will cheer everyone up let's
show a photo of your beautiful wife
extraordinary beautiful you realize
we're just how incredibly lucky you are
as a man Hey
yes III you know I figured if I'm going
to wake up every morning with one single
woman for the rest of my life I better
at least find her beautiful
yeah yeah thank you very nice it's a
little shallow but you can clap bill you
know I was I was thinking no but you
know that she is a really wonderful
person and that is really what makes it
the best because when someone is you
know yes someone's beautiful but you
also see them like plucking their
moustache before awards season oh you
know I don't know cleaning toejam I
don't know what do you do you know yeah
I don't know I'm looking you know you're
not you're not sleeping at home tonight
throw the television hard hits no women
don't have hair yes Kim Kardashian um
whoa
what now you're offended I mean know
exactly I'm with you hundred percent so
but again I'm so happy for you it's been
a year now and you're in marital bliss
is that way I really I really am I am
it's very blissful